[Musique]
cette semaine j'avais mon choix de
chronique des sujets super intéressant
un peu partout cependant je vais revenir
sur la dernière chronique que j'ai fait
celle où je parlais justement du fait
que le Vatican venait de répudier la
doctrine de la découverte celle qui
justement était accompagnée de
l'idéologie de terrain du lieu c'est à
dire que les Amériques étaient vides de
citoyens catholiques donc on pouvait
coloniser et convertir ces 10 non
citoyens pour pouvoir donner plus de
pouvoir au courant
européenne bien sûr le fait qu'on
répudie la doctrine de la découverte
c'était quand même très important pour
les communautés
c'est beaucoup passé en dessous du radar
par rapport aux nouvelles par rapport à
l'importance que ça l'a pour le reste
des Amériques on pourrait se mettre
d'accord sur le fait que mais maintenant
qui ont colonisé à quoi ça sert de
revenir sur le passé
mais je parlais de l'importance
justement de ce que ça représentait par
rapport aux valeurs par rapport à la
morale par rapport justement aussi au
traité non respecté etc pourquoi je
reviens sur cette chronique c'est parce
qu'elle rentre bien connexion avec le
sujet qui vient tout de suite après ce
long congé par Oscar qui a beaucoup fait
les les médias sociaux mais qui a encore
une fois un peu passé sous le radar à
mon avis c'est celle où notre premier
ministre monsieur François Legault a
retweeté
une chronique de Mathieu bocoté et dans
cette chronique on fait l'apologie
justement du bon vieux fonds catholique
de l'importance justement que l'esprit
communautaire qui est venu avec l'Église
eu par rapport à la colonisation de la
Nouvelle France bien sûr dans cette
chronique on fait absolument
complètement abstraction de la réalité
de ce que l'Église a fait aux
communautés qui existaient déjà sur ce
territoire donc on s'entend que c'est
une vision dans un tunnel cependant
ce qui est vraiment fantastique c'est
qu'au bout de ce tunnel on arrive avec
une réflexion autour de la société qui
va être divisée par le multiculturalisme
vous comprendrez que c'était assez
intéressant de voir comment un homme
d'État aussi important que monsieur
Legault un chroniqueur qui a autant de
visibilité que Mathieu BOC côté comment
ça faire
la gloire de l'Église catholique et dans
le fond des valeurs que l'Église a
apporté donc il y a ma chronique sur le
Vatican qui répudie justement ces
valeurs qui ont été à la base justement
de la création de la Nouvelle France du
Québec et présentement qui en plus on
sent une valorisation du vieux Fonds
québécois à l'encontre du
multiculturalisme bien sûr ça vient en
plus sur les traces de la loi pour la
laïcité de l'État vous comprendrez qu'il
y a une espèce d'aveuglement vraiment
volontaire par rapport à ce qui est dit
dans cette chronique et aussi dans ce
retouit parce que c'est un message quand
même assez fort pour les citoyens qu'on
voit notre premier ministre lancé dans
la toute sphère ce genre de message mais
pourquoi est-ce que je reviens sur ça
pourquoi est-ce que je rajoute le tweet
de Monsieur le goût c'est que dans les
commentaires que j'ai eu par rapport à
la chronique du Vatican on me demandait
mais pourquoi est-ce que c'est encore
aussi important pour vous la vision de
du pape pourquoi les maux du Vatican ont
de l'importance c'est quand on sait ce
que l'Église catholique que le les
religieux ont eu comme impact négatif
sur les communautés autochtones à
travers les pensionnats à travers
justement la
conversion forcée et des fois pas forcé
justement des communautés alors il y a
une vision qui existe qui est comme
celle du Québec qui est multiple
et il y a une compréhension aussi de par
rapport à comment l'Église est aussi
arrivée dans nos communautés elle n'est
pas arrivée de façon égale partout on
n'est pas tous des chrétiens catholiques
on peut y avoir de plusieurs origines de
religion comme dans l'état canadien
comme dans l'État québécois
cependant la réalité est que comme
pendant la Révolution tranquille des
membres des communs de la communauté
québécoise se sont tournées loin des
églises et ont commencé à vivre une vie
beaucoup plus laïque il restait quand
même beaucoup de manque se sont attachés
et qui ont resté attachés à l'église
catholique et bien dans la même réalité
puis déjà je vais parler beaucoup plus
du point de vue d'une inou mais ça
existe dans toutes les autres nations de
différentes de différentes comment je
peux dire
historiques justement avec la religion
que et bien on est allés vers la région
puisque notre spiritualité qui existait
qui n'était pas dogmatique qui était
vraiment très multi multiples sont
élimination selon le territoire qui est
invité et bien elle se rencontrait très
souvent et quand on croit au Grand
Esprit quand on
voit la création comme quelque chose de
sacré bien tout ce qui change souvent
les animaux qui sont sur le territoire
alors quand tu vas chasser le caribou tu
vas voir un papa classique un esprit qui
est très fort pour la protection du
caribou mais quand tu vas être avec
l'orignal mode va être un autre
personnage qui va être important dans la
spiritualité alors ces interactions là
faisaient qu'on peut pas avoir une
église unique un dogme un livre une
bible
alors plusieurs réflexions plusieurs
pensées qui s’échangeaient quand la
religion catholique est arrivée et bien
elle se superposait de façon quand même
assez
pratique à celle des religions
excusez-moi j'en ai spiritualité
autochtones donc un créateur qui a créé
le monde cependant il y a eu beaucoup
aussi de la crainte de l'enfer quelque
chose qui n'existait pas vraiment dans
les concepts autochtones et il y a eu de
la conversion il y a eu
[Musique]
un adoption aussi de la religion
catholique par les membres des
communautés parce qu'on était très
croyant par rapport à l'ensemble de ce
qui nous entourait de la nature et donc
ça le fait qu'une conversion pour
certains qui étaient beaucoup plus
facile d'autres c'était des conversions
forcées d'autres étaient des conversions
pays étaient si tu te fais baptiser tu
vas avoir un fusil on a eu ces histoires
là justement dans l'histoire du Québec
qui a été vraiment mis de l'avant
puisqu'on trouvait ça très très drôle
cependant on a aussi eu les pensionnats
et ça ça a été la version extrême
justement de la relation avec l'Église
par rapport aux membres autochtones donc
vous pouvez imaginer qu'il y a eu un une
séparation très claire entre les membres
des communautés qui ont vécu dans la
forêt qui ont pratiqué leur spiritualité
ou leur religion de façon libre dans la
forêt qui faisait la messe par eux-mêmes
c'était une liberté de religion à cette
époque-là et là tu vas dans les
pensionnats tu as toute la relation avec
les prêtres les religieuses qui est
extrêmement toxiques dangereuse voire
même mortel pour beaucoup de membres des
de la génération de mes parents de mes
grands-parents aussi
et là comme la Révolution tranquille et
bien il y a beaucoup de membres des
communautés qui se sont tournées
complètement qui ont tourné le dos à
l'église à la religion sont revenus vers
une spiritualité qui était beaucoup plus
clairement très contact très église et
donc même dans nos communautés il y a
une division par rapport aux visions
religieuses ou vision spirituelles elles
existent alors quand on parle de
l'importance du
desédits du Vatican et bien on voit
justement le pouvoir de l'église encore
sur beaucoup de membres de notre
communauté on va aussi comment ces
textes-là pour nous on a une implication
légale puisque ça a été des gestes
illégaux ou légaux qui ont été faits
mais le truc c'est que le monde mais
pourquoi est-ce que vous crachez pas sur
les listes pourquoi vous brunez vous
brûlez pas les églises c'est vrai on
aurait pu il y avait toute une espèce de
colère accumulée surtout quand on s'est
mis à trouver les corps sur les anciens
sites des pensionnats les gens étaient
étonnés qu'on n'est pas plus de colère
c'est qu'on avait aussi un grand respect
pour nos aînés qui eux sont encore très
croyants par rapport à l'église ou même
qui ont plusieurs croyances des fois des
croyances qui sont dit à l'église et
aussi à la spiritualité traditionnelle
qui se sont entre Miley donc il y a ce
passage là vers une guérison qui fait
partie justement de notre notre vision
du futur c'est à dire ok c'est arrivé on
pourra jamais effacer la blessure que
l'Église a créé sur nos communautés on
pourra jamais
faire semblant que c'est jamais arrivé
parce qu'il y a un impact mais cependant
on peut laisser la souffrance de la
douleur derrière et vivre avec cette
cicatrice là d'une manière qui va nous
permettre de mieux vivre pas une
blessure qui fait encore mal qui fait
encore souffrir mais une blessure qui va
être un rappel justement de ce qu'on ne
veut pas de ce qui doit éviter alors
quand on entend des des commentaires ou
des tweets tels que celui avec une
vision en tunnel qui dit que c'était
donc inspirant émerveilleux il y a
justement un aveuglement volontaire par
rapport à ce qui ne l'a pas été par
rapport justement au fait que ce qui
était apprécié c'était la dominance
grâce à la pluie de l'église du
territoire déjà occupé et présentement
ça permet de justifier aussi de pouvoir
rejeter d'autres personnes qui viennent
habiter le territoire de la même manière
que les citoyens de la Nouvelle France
sont venus habiter donc il y a vraiment
une création encore une fois dominante
qui est utilisé par la vision de
l'église alors que clairement le Vatican
lui dit non il faut qu'on transforme
cette vision là il faut qu'on en sorte
ses visions de minantes de dominer aussi
parce que si j'entends souvent il y a
toujours eu les dominant et les dominé
dans ces commentaires que je reçois et
bien on doit en faire l'exclusion pour
pouvoir aller vers une église qui se
renouvelle qui se guérit et permettre
cette relation justement entre nos
communautés celles qui sont encore
croyantes celles qui sont encore très
spirituel de pouvoir se guérir elle
aussi alors si c'est vision qui sont
portées par des personnes qui ont des
pouvoirs dans l'état continuent d'être
porté à travers des tweets à travers des
visions très idéalisées de justement
l'église du passé en bien continuer à
traîner des problèmes sur les 500
dernières années vers les 500 prochaines
années alors que l'Église elle-même
commence à travailler sur une réparation
euh autour des membres justement de son
église et vous comprendrez que oui le
Vatican a encore du pouvoir oui encore
des personnes des communautés
autochtones qui sont très croyantes et
d'autres qui le sont pas mais par
exemple il y a une transition vers une
guérison qui doit être fait et non pas
sur garder la plaie ouverte et en créer
de nouvelles justement avec des citoyens
qui habitent sur ce territoire comme
toutes les autres citoyens du Québec et
du Canada alors si mon partage de ma
vision bien sûr il en existe énormément
d'autres
mais je pense que notre identité est
multiple j'en suis un peu le fruit
et je pense que ça ça
si on trouve des solutions pour tous il
y a un espoir justement pour que cette
identité-là à laquelle on tient
justement puisse être portée en même
temps que celle des autres il y a de la
place au soleil pour tout le monde alors
je souhaite une belle semaine je vous
remercie énormément pour votre écoute
votre patience et vous comprendrez
pourquoi cette chronique était très
importante pour moi dans mon sens et
aussi par rapport à pourquoi il faut
mettre en place un sujet si difficile et
comme beaucoup de gens ont dit il va
falloir qu'on revienne souvent sur cette
discussion là puisque c'est 500 ans de
rattrapage qu'on a à faire alors je
souhaite une belle semaine